[Musique]
emploi mal rémunéré personnel en burn
out le système de santé français vit
donc une crise sans précédent maintenant
que les urgences de l'hôpital d'Orléans
sont en pleine tourmente le service fait
face à une vague d'arrêt maladie des
soignants
on recueille tout aux urgences on se
retrouve avec des gens qui auraient très
bien fait d'aller voir leur médecin
traitant mais vu qu'ils en ont pas
malheureusement c'est nous qui les
accueillons les gens en ont plus de
reconnaissance sont fatigués quittent la
profession et puis on ferme les lits
parce qu'il y a plus de personnels pour
les faire marcher c'est corps fatigués
par la crise du covid plus ce qui avait
avant a fait que ça s'est dégradé
rapidement là nous ça craque et puis on
se rend compte qu'au bout de quatre mois
très peu de choses qui ont changé
vous rappelez tout à l'heure vous aviez
fait un malaise ça vous parle ou pas
vous savez plus trop
comme une crise d'épilepsie
donc en fait il faudrait qu'on vous
fasse une ponction lombaire
une petite piqûre d'accord prendre le
temps expliquer rassurer réaliser le
geste médical
Christophe devin va consacrer 30 minutes
de sa garde à cette patient âgée
un luxe pour un lundi soir aux urgences
du CHR d'Orléans
pourtant depuis l'après covid la réalité
du quotidien est tout autre là on
commence à
saturations
même les toilettes des fois on a nulle
part ailleurs que derrière les paravents
dans les couloirs
[Musique]
des dizaines de brancards dans les
couloirs des patients en attente depuis
plus de 36 heures le service des
urgences est très régulièrement saturé
il y avait des brancards des deux côtés
des couloirs
le temps dédié aux patients il est nul
il est nul on fait de la médecine de
guerre quoi on fait de la
je sais même pas comment vous dire quoi
c'est pas de la fumée de la médecine
qu'on fait c'est du tri en fait ce qu'on
fait là en ce moment c'est
ni fait ni à faire
c'est moi je sors de régulation j'ai
honte
il y a vraiment des fois où j'ai le où
on dit vraiment aux gens démerdez-vous
quoi
façon de parler mais il y a des petites
solutions mais c'est on met des
pansements sur une hémorragie active
[Musique]
au moment de la crise au printemps
dernier une claque reçue pour cette
jeune diplômée
le plus insupportable c'est vraiment la
maltraitance la maltraitance le
non-respect de la pudeur de l'intimité
de l'anonymat surtout aussi
c'était un peu devenu de la bataille et
je ne respectais plus les patients et je
me respectais puni moi-même et ma
profession et ça ça a été le plus dur
[Musique]
ce n'était donc plus possible il fallait
un électrochoc un ultime recours se
mettre en grève
c'est pas vous le chef ici d'accord
non non non calmez-vous c'est pas vous
le chef ici d'accord vous m'enlevez tout
ça rentrer chez moi non vous rentrerez
pas monsieur bon d'accord depuis avril
dernier les urgences fonctionnent en
mode dégradé couloir de traumatologie
fermée départ de 10 infirmières
aujourd'hui 11 médecins se relaient jour
et nuit il en faudrait le double alors
faute de personnel l'accès au service
est limité au stricts urgences vitales
là typiquement on fait plus de petites
traumas on fait plus de suture on fait
plus de plâtre les gens qui se font en
entorse c'est mettez de la glace
attendez demain
mais
on devrait être en capacité de les voir
à 37 ans Nesrine n'estblit a repris la
direction du service le premier juillet
dernier passé par la faculté de Tours
elle a fait son internationalement au
CHR d'Orléans elle a choisi d'y rester
car elle s'y plaît après il faut appeler
l'administrateur de garde c'est Madame
DIMACIO cette semaine et tu lui dis que
c'est un patient pour la neuro refusé de
la neuro et que c'est un patient Nini
avec un problème social
et que il faut qu'elle impose dans un
service oui alors pour Monsieur
terminé courageuse mais réaliste elle
doit faire face à la concentration des
obstacles en fait là je l'ai vu il vient
pour chute à répétition lui il veut
rentrer chez lui il est oxygéné nos
dépendant le peur que j'ai c'est que si
on laisse rentrer chez lui avec son
oxygène bon certes on peut le sevrer en
oxygène mais si c'est pour qui rechute
que sa femme elle le trouve complètement
par terre et qu'elle puisse pas le gérer
que ça soit un épuisement familial ben
c'est ça donc je pense que lui il faut
quand même qu'il soit hospitalisé moi 48
72 heures quoi l'un des grands enjeux du
bon fonctionnement d'un hôpital la
répartition des patients dans les autres
services après leur arrivée aux urgences
j'ai aucune place ailleurs donc pour
l'instant j'ai pas de vision sur l'htcd
et là depuis plus d'une journée donc je
vais voir avec nesris si on assouplit la
règle de l'uhld et s'il y a des places
qui se libèrent ce qui est pas sûr mais
voilà j'ai aucun lit pour cette dame le
problème des urgences c'est le manque de
vie Daval c'est pas un problème de flux
je crois pas enfin ce qui me concerne
c'est surtout qu'on sait pas quoi faire
des gens
c'est toujours de pire en pire donc ça
devient épuisant
l'impression que outre le fait d'être
médecin faut être négociateur
aujourd'hui ah oui il faut être vendeur
je crois que j'aille vendre des voitures
bientôt
je vais essayer de vous trouver un lit
pour vous hospitaliser
le retour à la maison avec un lit
d'oxygène et le fait que vous tombiez
tout le temps à la maison vous pouvez
pas marcher là correctement chez vous
donc il faut qu'on fasse le point sur
vos chutes je peux pas vous laisser
rentrer comme ça chez vous il faut
rester à la maison je peux le faire je
suis toujours assis dans mon fauteuil
on va voir avec vos dames si elle est
d'accord d'abord
le vieillissement de la population le
manque de médecin généraliste la prise
en charge sociale des patients d'autres
raisons rendent laborieux l'exercice de
la médecine pure et simple
ça me paraît être compliqué dans la
situation actuelle de laisser rentrer
chez lui avec le risque qui reviennent
dans dans la foulée parce qu'il a
rechuté à nouveau à domicile ou que la
femme soit pas capable de le gérer ils
ont leur pathologie qui les amènent ici
mais ils ont aussi leurs problèmes
sociaux leurs problèmes de maintien à
domicile donc avant de laisser une
passion impatient fragile rentrer chez
lui il faut être sûr qu'il est ce qu'il
faut à domicile
ça va pas s'améliorer
ça va pas s'améliorer en fait on a une
population vieillissante mais pour qui
on a pas l'offre de soins qui suit
mais est-ce que l'État le veut vraiment
je me demande la question si l'objectif
final de l'État n'est pas un écroulement
du service de santé publique
c'est-à-dire que derrière ça sera des
soins privés ou ce weekend l'argent
pourra se faire soigner et celui qui
n'en a pas restera chez lui
face à cet afflux de passion et la
fermeture de lit la direction de
l'hôpital est démunie pour le directeur
le problème est structurel chronique
nos difficultés principales elles tient
pas au fonctionnement des urgences qui
fonctionnent bien mais elle tient
effectivement à l'aval ou notamment en
médecine on a beaucoup de lit fermé pour
vous donner une idée cet été on a eu 320
lits fermés 320 litres fermés ça
représente un tiers des capacités de
l'hôpital comme je crois que la crise
est systémique et bien mon idée
maintenant mon souhait c'est que nous
parvenions à dialoguer avec la ville
avec les acteurs de ville parce que en
fait cette crise elle a montré aussi que
l'hôpital il peut pas faire tout seul
voilà il peut plus faire tout seul
d'accord mais là vous vous sentez bien
d'accord il y a pas il y a pas de
malaise pas de douleur
d'accord je vais vous passer le médecin
ne quitter pas
la sensation que son cœur bat moins vite
depuis plusieurs mois qui a pas de
douleur qui sent très bien mais qui dit
juste au bout de plusieurs mois que
peut-être son traitement pouvait
provoquer ça c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait très bien être vu avec un
médecin traitant et qui relève pas du
tout de passer par nous
depuis la crise dans le service la porte
d'entrée de l'hôpital n'est plus les
urgences mais le centre de régulation
des appels secours le 15 ici beaucoup
d'appels sont abusifs parfois même
farfelus la question d'urgence est
devenue toute relative une question de
pédagogie
c'est à l'État d'éduquer la population
et je pense qu'il faut commencer depuis
le plus jeune âge à l'école tout
simplement
à l'école c'est à dire que il y a des
patients qui appellent juste parce
qu'ils ont mal à la tête et qu'ils ont
rien pris
ou qui ont 39 de fièvre depuis 10
minutes et qui appelle au 15 des gens
ils ont même pas de pharmacie chez eux
donc ils ont même pas de quoi faire un
pansement ils ont pas de quoi donner du
doliprane un enfant qui a de la fièvre
ils ont même pas un antiémétique à
domicile donc je pense qu'il faut
apprendre aux gens que on peut pas sur
consommer du sang
qui sont comme ça donc c'est Olivier il
y a le numéro et l'adresse et vous
pouvez directement aller aux urgences
là-bas ils sont ils s'occuperont de vous
on est passé dans une société un peu du
consumérisme médical sachant
qu'effectivement la responsabilisation
des patients est aussi quelque chose
d'important mais là encore une fois
c'est pas moi directeur
du CHR d'Orléans qui veulent décréter
c'est quelque chose à faire tous
ensemble et avec des campagnes
d'éducation de formation à la santé donc
il y a tout un travail à faire
certainement pour améliorer nos
dispositifs parce que l'hôpital n'est
pas un recours inépuisable voilà
en 1990 7 millions de patients sont
passés aux urgences en France
trois décennies plus tard ce nombre a
atteint 22 millions plus de trois fois
plus
maisons médicalisée digital accueille
direct en cardiologie création d'un sas
de sortie des patients des mesures
urgentes ont été mises en place par la
direction mais la crise à l'hôpital est
abyssale et Orléans en est la parfaite
incarnation
[Musique]
c'est compliqué de dire qu'il y a pas
d'espoir
a priori tant qu'on est pas parti c'est
qu'il y a des sports
enfin il faut il faut il faut faire avec
ce qu'on a et
il faut essayer de bien prendre en
charge les gens
on est encore quelques années à passer
qui vont être très difficiles puisque
vous savez que le premier ministre a
annoncé donc la transformation du CHR en
CHU on sait que les étudiants en
médecine ils vont pas sortir tout de
suite diplômés il faudra attendre 2031
donc on a tendance on va avoir des
années difficiles à traverser
il faut essayer de rester dans une
dynamique positive en se disant on va y
arriver on va tout faire pour y arriver
mais je dis pas qu'il y a des jours où
je me dis que de toute façon ça changera
jamais et que
il faut peut-être partir
et je me dis que parfois est-ce que j'ai
pas
fait la bonne la bonne profession
jeunesse unité humanité les urgences
survivent grâce aux personnel
hospitalier
se lever venir au travail prendre soin
des patients
oui mais pour encore combien de temps
[Musique]